bonjour thomas porte merci de répondre à
nos questions en direct sur rt france on
vient d'entendre donc dispersion des
militants de l'ultra-gauche sur ce
quartier montparnasse la place du 18
juin 40
est ce que vous craignez des
affrontements au cours de cet après midi
à une manifestation sauvage suite à
cette dispersion ou vont aller selon
vous les militant-es qui vont aller
rejoindre certains ont essayé de rallier
le le rassemblement place denfert
rochereau
voilà est-ce que vous avez peur pour
pour cet après midi non j'ai pas peur
qu'il y ait des violences je crois que
les militantes et les militants qui
étaient réunis cet après-midi l'ont fait
sur un mot d'ordre simple c'est-à-dire
dénoncé laurent semblant de génération
identitaire qui est quand même un
groupuscule qui s'apprête à être dissous
et donne ton autorise la manifestation
et en parallèle dans interdite celle des
organisations progressistes donc le
préfet l'allemand qu'on avait connue
violent sur les mobilisations sociales
continuent dans ses choix de dire dans
quel camp il se place et aujourd'hui
c'est carrément inacceptable qu'on ait
autorisé une manifestation de génération
identitaire qu'on n'ait pas accepté
celle de des militants de gauche mais je
crois qu'il n'y a pas de risque de
violence les manifestations c'est parce
que la demande a été déposée hors délai
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
manifestation des militants
d'ultragauche a été un non autorisées
oui mais vous avez vu la participation
on parle pas de milliers de personnes si
la préfecture de paris de paris
le préfet de police avait voulu que
cette manifestation soutiennent elles se
seraient tenues
d'ailleurs il interdit la manifestation
mais il met quand même un dispositif
policier très important au tour donc
c'est qu'il prend en compte cette
manifestation donc c'est véritablement
un choix politique de l'interdire c'est
un signal qui est donné
c'est vraiment un beau final dans la
période vous parlez de signal politique
justement quel signal politique on voit
selon-vous gérald darmanin qu'on a un
col t il parle de dissoudre donc le
mouvement anti-immigration génération
identitaire et de l'autre côté on évoque
une surenchère sécuritaire dans son
discours notamment quand on a vu son
débat qui l'a opposé à marine le pen
récemment est ce qu'il ya une position
ambiguë de la part du locataire de la
place beauvau selon vous je crois qu'il
ya deux sujets dans votre question il ya
la dissolution des générations
identitaire qui est absolument
nécessaire parce qu'on parle comme
l'organisation qui viennent de se voir
ouvrir une procédure judiciaire contre
elle pour incitation à la haine en
raison de la race une organisation qui a
reçu des dons d'un terroriste à l'époque
de brent a tué 50 personnes a trahi
cherche on parle d'une organisation qui
va à la frontière se substituer aux
forces républicaines donc qui agit comme
une milice donc la dissolution elle est
absolument nécessaire elle doit être
prise ça fait d'ailleurs des années
qu'on demande cette dissolution après
sur la position de gérald darmanin
personne n'est dupe
c'est pas parce qu'aujourd'hui le
ministre de l'intérieur va engager la
dissolution des générations identitaire
qu'on ne va pas combattre ses idées et
son discours qui sert aujourd'hui de
marchepied à l'extrême droite et on a vu
sur les dernières semaines à la fois au
travers du débat ou quand même monsieur
d'armes anr a accusé madame le pen
d'être trop molle où il a dit
textuellement que des articles de la loi
sur le séparatisme été réalisés pour
faire plaisir au rassemblement national
et on a eu en plus ces derniers jours un
complément la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche qui est venu
nous sortir des enquêtes du cnrs sur l'i
stem aux gauchistes
donc effectivement il ya une
droitisation extrême du discours du
gouvernement mais c'est pas une surprise
pour nous ça fait des mois qu'on le
dénonce je rappelle quand même qu
emmanuel macron a commencé son
quinquennat en mettant en place une loi
anti terroriste ce qui est inscrit dans
le droit ordinaire des dispositifs de la
juridiction d'exception
donc c'est vraiment un discours
absolument inquiétant que tient ce
gouvernement qui s'inscrit dans une
stratégie politique aussi dangereuse
puisque ce que vise emmanuel macron
c'est un second tour face à l'extrême
droite pour dire je vais être élu je
serai le rempart l'assemblée nationale
c'est aujourd'hui ça le scénario qu'on
essaie de nous imposer c'est ce qu'on
tente de déjouer aussi
ensemble à la gauche sur un projet
politique vous venez d'évoquer dans des
chefs d'accusation
visant génération identitaire
constitution de milices on a entendu tu
as his death cuffaut au micro de david
khalifa elle a dit que donc son groupe
avait déjà été relaxé concernant ce chef
d'accusation et concernant l'autre chef
d'accusation d'incitation à la haine
génération identitaire n'a jamais été
condamné donc du coup selon eux pas
d'inquiétude concernant leur dissolution
comment est-ce que vous réagissez aux
propos de thaïs discuterons porte parole
donc de génération identitaire au micro
tout à l'heure de david khalifa d'abord
sur le deuxième chef d'accusation la
procédure elle est en cours donc dire
qu'on n'a pas été condamné c'est un peu
facile la justice décidera mais on est
véritablement sur une opération de
milices puisque quand vous allez dans
des frontières que vous contrôlez les
frontières que vous voulez arrêter des
gens que vous le voulez les prendre en
photo ou en vidéo pour les livrer à la
police
on est sur des opérations de
substitution à l'ordre républicain et
enfants et aux forces de vos missions de
maintien de l'ordre de l'état donc c'est
véritablement une milice qui s'organise
et vous savez il ya quelques années
génération humanitaire a lancé une vidéo
avec des termes extrêmement guéret le
titre de la vidéo c'était déclaration de
guerre voilà aujourd'hui ce que ces
générations identitaire une organisation
violente qui terrorise le grand
emplacement c'est pas un militant de
gauche qui a été abattu par la police il
ya quelques mois en emportant une
doudoune d'une génération identitaire
qui braquait un chef d'entreprise
d'origine étrangère c'est aujourd'hui ça
la réalité c'est la seule organisation
française qui reçoit des dons de
terroristes il ya des liens qui sont
affirmés avec ces groupuscules là et
aujourd'hui on peut pas continuer à
avoir une organisation qui promeut laine
qui souffle sur des braises qui
instrumentalisent l'immigration pour
rejeter l'autre génération et d'inserts
porte la question par exemple de l'art
et immigration on a de ses porte paroles
il savait le pierre loti qui elle
quelques mois sur une vidéo dit les
juifs de rentrer chez eux
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas acceptable et
les discours porté par génération
humanitaire y compris leurs actions sont
contraires aux valeurs de la république
c'est sont extrêmement dangereuses
puisqu'elles peuvent entraîner le
passage à l'acte et des mouvements
violents derrière petit ce n'est pas
acceptable en 2018
avait qualifié le groupe génération
identitaire je cite de néo-nazis est-ce
que c'est acceptable également est-ce
que vous maintenez vos propos on est la
procédure puisque vous êtes poursuivi
par génération identitaire pour avoir
utilisé ces mots vous êtes poursuivi
pour injures publiques
oui je suis je suis poursuivi donc vous
la procédure est toujours en cours et
mon procès aura lieu au début du mois de
septembre
vous comprenez bien que je peux pas
m'exprimer sur cette affaire là pour des
questions de procédure mais je ne suis
pas le seul militant ou militantes qui
sont aujourd'hui poursuivis assigné en
justice par génération identitaire qui
essaye de faire taire toutes celles et
ceux qui dénoncent ce qu'ils sont pour
apparaître plus blanc que blanc mais au
fond des choses on sait de quoi il
s'agit et je terminerai là dessus quand
génération identitaire organise des
soi-disant maraude solidaire pour
distribuer de la nourriture simplement
aux sdf français
c'est quelque part une forme de racisme
déguisé puisque on exclut une majorité
de la population
donc effectivement le racisme n'est pas
une opinion c'est un délit et la
dissolution de génération identitaire
elle doit être prise de manière
extrêmement rapide
merci thomas port d'avoir répondu à nos
questions direction arte france je
rappelle que vous êtes parti à rolle
deux générations le mouvement de benoît
hamon